everyone's had lots about cookies and
but an interest is a funny term is an
interesting one and people see them and
increasingly what you'll see is you see
that little window pop up on websites in
Europe which says we use cookies to
enhance the user experience and please
click that you accept this so why is
that window there of what's happened
well cookies are great at enhancing the
years of experience and what talk a
little bit about what that means and but
they're also obviously there was a
little bit of a warning so are they good
or are they bad let's start by what are
they well the way in which underlying
while wait web works is that essentially
it's a distributed system okay which
means that there are places that hold
information and there are things that
ask for that information so your
computer say which would look a little
bit like this with you would say please
give me something it would respond and
say here you go so if you imagine a page
and on here that says hello the
information for that page would come
over here
I would appear in your screen and we've
done this lots of times some machine say
in your house is asking a machine in
Australia for this information
the very first protocols the very first
means by which this is done took a very
simple means of doing this what they
decided was that they would be what's
called stateless so this machine would
simply say it's a new page here's a page
here's a page what that meant for you as
a user would be if you went away came
back had a cup of tea and then went to
the exactly the same place and asked for
the same information there would be no
knowledge whatsoever about you haven't
done it before which became a little bit
selling so how then do you do the little
shopping carts there's often a little a
little shopping cart in the corner and
as you go through
and you buy things it puts things in the
cart or how would you know that if you
don't remember who's asked for the
information and what the last about so
that's what cookies are about the world
no changes
so let's no put a cookie in so imagine
you're on this page you see give me the
page and you get the page with all the
details but you're also within that
we'll have little tiny files called
cookies cookies a low vest machine to
remember information about the last page
it gave you which means as you purchase
things they can be added to this and so
that when you go away and combat that
information is remembered so preferences
can be said you can decide things so
layouts of things can be can be done
which using to happen before so the
whole thing from end to end gets called
a session so it's no different then
putting your shoes and to be repaired
and the man gives you a ticket and then
you go back and you use the ticket and
you get the Rach pair of shoes back so
they're sold sounds good that enhances
everything but they have started to
become really quite controversial as
well the real issue about this actually
you probably best have a little think
about a web page here many web pages
that you go to give you information for
free and have you ever wondered how
people can do that why can you get
something for nothing well what happens
often and increasingly you'll see this
is you see web page has been a bit like
this and then there'll be the content
that you're looking up there okay so in
my case this would be stuff about
football okay
so I'd be looking up my favorite team's
football scores but I'll notice all
these scrolling ads around here the
adverbs are generating revenue for that
page in order to do that and that's
where cookies get controversial the
example I've given you is what's called
first-party cookies when one party is
given an information to another what
actually happens here is rather
interesting because use
in one page but actually what's
happening is a range of things this
could be the part where you're asking
for this page and you're getting the
content but all these aren't valves
could be coming from completely
different parts of the world and
alphadon are okay so these can all are
all companies which are sailing up the
art that means that the web page
although it may be WWI favorite sitcom
all these other sites are also putting
information into that page so this can
enhance the experience by remembering
who you are by putting a little fail
down all of these when they put the
information down are also putting a
cookie down so no all of these
advertising agencies also remember that
you've been on this page so these guys
can start to talk to each other and then
form an advertising network which can
start to remember your preferences and
where you've been on the world wide web
this is basically known as tracking or
cookie tracking these third-party
cookies hello the advertisers to figure
Oh have you seen this advert before and
even to sequence a number of our vets so
they can decide that some others and
some things that people punches the
punches after see in a sequence of
adverts and they can do that sequence
and because they've remembered where
those things are we probably do need to
know just how much people know about
where you browse how you browse and what
your browsing purchases are because many
many millions or billions of sessions
can be analyzed so are you the person
who browsers in a particular way I'll
use somebody who punches things in
different way so all of these cookies
are low little trails they can be netted
together and analyzed to understand your
behavior and that's why the EU
introduced as part of their privacy
measures this thing called the cookie
law and the cookie law said where
you've got to inform people that you've
captured information about them and then
allow them to opt out so those little
screens that appear do that there are no
problems here one of the problems here
is the EU have legislated for this so
this has been browsers in the EU if you
try and go through the same site you
probably won't see those things okay but
the interesting thing about those is
either cookies off or it's cookies on
many people talk about perhaps what you
want to low is one party cookies but not
third party cookies as always with
computers these things that can all be
done and even in the current systems you
can do most of these they're very
difficult to present to users and very
different for users to find so so you
will if you really want to dig down deep
be able to do this but it's not quite as
obvious there's also quite a lot of
scare stories about cookies cookies are
not programs okay
when cookies go onto your machine they
don't run as code so that means they
can't really give you a virus which is
we one of the dangers that people would
have the can't and in and of themselves
take all the elements of your screen or
even your webcam the worry everyone has
though is the start of allowing all of
that to happen without anybody noticing
and there's been quite a lot of
controversy about this and and people
don't realize that so if I ask you the
question I do ask it now so how many of
these cookies and many third parties do
you think they'd be on a site on one on
one page one side I'm going to think
you've simplified that book you've got
three or four so maybe six or seven okay
so so so they're the interesting thing
is every one of those gives you a tiny
amount of money